- [Jason] Revelers in Times Square
on January 1st, 2020 expressed
the usual optimism about the new year.
- This is our year.
This is the world's year.
- It's gonna be a great year.
- Little did they know that
where they were standing
would, in just a few months,
due to the Corona virus
pandemic, become a ghost town.
What a difference a year makes.
This December 31st,
there'll be no crowds here
in Times Square as in so many
other cities around the world
that the pandemic is putting
a damper on celebrations.
This year, the glimmering
crystal ball will still count
the world down into a new year,
but the hundreds of thousands of people
who normally line up the blocks
and brave the elements will
be reduced to a small
group of invited guests.
- [Hosts] Three, two, one!
- Happy new Year!
- [Jason] Carson Daly,
who's been in Times
Square on New Year's Eve
for NBC since 2004, is adapting.
- I don't think it's going
to be like happy new year,
it's two minutes away!
And all the, you know,
the background, obviously,
is going to be completely different.
You know, usually if you
see me on Times Square,
you know, I'm like,
hey, where are you from?
Where are you from? Where are you?
Oh, you drove from here?
You flew from Peru, blah, blah, blah.
It's so exciting here, guys.
- [Jason] The tradition
of often-shivering crowds,
assembling shoulder to
shoulder in Times Square
to ring in the new year as
the ball drops dates back
more than 100 years.
There've been only two years
when the ball didn't drop,
1942 and 1943, when the
ceremony was suspended due
to the wartime dim out of
lights in New York City.
But this year, the show will go on,
staged for an at-home audience,
according to the president
of the Times Square Alliance,
which helps coordinate the event.
- There will be a live
broadcast event in Times Square,
but there will not be a public audience.
It will simply be a broadcast
stage for the entire world
to see.
- [Announcer] Ring in a
year that has to be better.
- [Jason] Broadcasters will be live
without the raucous crowds below.
- Celebrate with us.
- You sort of have to
kind of nail the tone
on a night like this,
because this has been just
a horrific year for so many,
because lives have been lost,
not to mention, if it wasn't
lives, it was livelihoods.
So, and then there's some
people that, you know,
may not have been affected.
So, and everything in between.
So, the tone, I think, is, is to be,
you know, optimistic and
hopeful, but reflective.
- [Jason] The NYPD will
bar the general public
from congregating anywhere
near Times Square.
- The only people that
will be there besides
the performers will be about 40 people
who are our invited special guests.
- In years past, the onstage production
featured special guests who
joined the mayor in pressing
the Waterford button that
triggers the ball drop.
This year, first responders, frontline
and essential workers
will be the ones honored,
but they'll remain in
socially-distant seating areas
with their families,
rather than pressing the countdown button.
The audience will also include
a small group of guests
who've rented, for the night,
this dome on NASDAQ's terrace,
overlooking Times Square.
Airbnb, which debuted on
NASDAQ earlier in December,
says the guests who signed up
for this marketing gimmick are paying $21.
New York isn't alone in finding ways
to adapt new year
celebrations to the pandemic.
Some cities are canceling them altogether.
As Americans start the
day on December 31st,
Sydney will kick off the new year
with a scaled down version of
its annual fireworks display.
Hong Kong is doing away entirely
with its fireworks display
over Victoria Harbor.
Officials say it's due to the pandemic.
The government also canceled it last year,
citing the threat posed by
antigovernment protesters.
London, now in lockdown, has
canceled all public events,
including its firework show.
And Las Vegas, which earlier
launched an ad campaign
to let people know it's open again,
won't hold its annual
pyrotechnics display on the strip.
Instead, the city is
promoting a virtual event
where it plans to blow
up a 2020 sign, live,
at an undisclosed location.
Here in New York City,
where there've been around
20,000 deaths from COVID,
the organizers of the event
say they want the tone,
despite the pandemic, to
be celebratory and hopeful.
- Staring at the ball,
being a part of such a rich,
American, iconic visual
of this ball dropping,
I feel like will really
make people feel like, okay,
it's official now, it's 2021,
and a sense of relief,
and a sense of hope.
- [Jason] And in a nod
to the year that was,
two-time Grammy award
winner, Gloria Gaynor,
will sing the lyrics.
- Go on now, walk out that
door and just turn around now,
you're not welcome anymore,
which I think is the way
we all feel about 2020.
- [Jason] The message from
public officials worldwide,
you can help make 2021 a year to celebrate
by spending new years at home.
(light music)